je l'aï dit et je m'étais lui deux ânes
général de cinéma c'est quoi vous
l'intention de vous chanter tout le
temps ici par exemple la maxime kenny
c'est toi je sens que tout le temps
c'est qui alors vous c'est quoi iritano
je mange mange mange mon bateau gitana
team one off
un jour je
un vrai problème je n'arrive pas à
retenir des paroles des chansons d'abba
paca en anglais français vivendi et ce
métier lui disais si les rats de cinéma
très bien
[Applaudissements]
vous c'est quoi ton michel moi c'est le
chanteur malheureux de cloclo asie et je
me demande si tu existes encore et je me
demande si ton coeur et au nord excusez
moi mais tu fais pour le soir émission
dépression après sa très belle chanson
hey boy bon avec le pot ale serbie sur
maxime attention j'ai une dent qu'il de
cinéma et un brise glace et vous c'est
quoi vos boutures sont comme moi c est
sheeran
mais ce n'est pas vrai a chanté je sais
pas chanter mais s'il me ça va la triple
d'heure mais là les arrêts par omnium
géraldine maillet sur castaldi ah oui
non oui une vraie morale quand même la
gamme tient sans doute à moi ou elle va
y aller là où s'ouvrira sous terre
brûlée au vent dès lors qu'ils feront
est ce que j'attends d'être une s'il
vous plaît vraiment plaisir c'est
vraiment sympa
[Applaudissements]
avec lui j'ai appris qu'il avait été
bien géré a dit moi j'aime bien lucio
battisti alors je chanterai à peine soit
et quoi ça c'est quoi c'est une chanson
de pizzérias a annoncé une très très
belle chance à cette année ce sont des
bons et la casse à peine sauter si on a
une mozzarella la merci des beignets de
moteur il va arriver tout seul la merci
et vous jean-luc j'ai attrapé ça vient
ça allait mal et les sharks au chant
d'ailleurs s'il attrape un coup de
piston qui met de la crème vilaine peau
de roule
non mais c'est vrai mais c'est quelque
chose qui se pratique tous les six mois
en reçoit tous cas vous n'essayez pas si
vous voulez je peux essayer vous voulez
mais c'est isabelle il avait d'accord tu
y vas y relate j'arrive
j'arrive à lui que vous est inconnu mais
vous rigolez mais non cette chanson
préférée c'est quoi oui c'est pas son
célèbre chat vous n'aimez pas su
retourner parce que j'aime toutes les
chansons mais c'est très souvent c'est
bien sûr c'est ben beau léo balley
paquet d'aidés la donne a punk et mimie
mathy
hélas
[Musique]